we're going to talk about the new
location based game pokemon gold like in
the old Pokemon games you walk around
and you collect pokemons but the new
thing is that this time you're not
walking around on your Gameboy and
you're in your virtual game space but
this time you're actually walking around
the city and you collect pokemons
wherever they appear in the city first
you download the app from the iPhone
store or the Android store so we have a
couple of streets here you need to be
outside because the game uses GPS to
track your position so this is us and we
actually physically walk around the city
with our phones in our hand and then
hopefully suddenly a Pokemon appears and
then when we're there we see the Pokemon
on our screen it switches to like a very
simple augmented reality view with your
camera and then we use the pokeballs and
do a very simple flicking game so I have
a I have a poker ball here and then I
have to try to throw it at the Pokemon
and if it works the Pokemon is captured
by the ball and then goes into my my
backpack or as it's called a Pokemon
Lingle my pokedex so we're here at the
University and over here is a poker
stock and if we do this we get bonus
items that we need and there's also
Pokemon next to it let's see if it works
I've hit it but now it might escape so
we need to wait a few seconds and has
escaped so let's try again I need to I
need to I need to hit the Pokemon with
the ball by flicking it in this
direction and my aim is very very bad at
the moment yeah so I've hit it now goes
into the ball and depending on the
strength of the Pokemon and my level and
the quality of pokeball I've used it
might or might not escape yeah gotcha
Psyduck was caught so I got experience
points for it and Stardust and candy I
already had that one yes no because
because GPS is very imprecise anyways it
works really well when you're driving on
a street because then the phone knows
that you are on a street so it will
watch the results a bit and actually put
you on the street but if you were just
walking around then the GPS will jump
around a little bit
at some point I will run out of these
pokeballs because I only have a limited
amount of them so what my antic has also
done is they placed so called poker
stops in the environment and I can see
them on the map that I have and then if
I walk to these poker stops I get bonus
items pokeballs etc so I can refresh my
energy basically and then there is a
another type of location so called Jim's
now when I walk to a Jim I can place one
of my pokemons inside this Jim and then
the Pokemon is protecting the Jim and I
can leave the spot again I can walk
around further collect other pokemons
train these pokemons and then if another
player comes to the gym they can fight
against my pokémon that is protecting
the Jim yeah that actually look very
much like a like a boxing ring so you
have like a platform and you can see the
two pokemons fighting against each other
each Pokemon is using their their
special abilities there are about 750
different pokemons in this game I will I
believe and in the the overall Pokemon
world there are plenty more so I'm sure
Niantic and Nintendo will release a
couple of more as soon as everybody has
found all the pokemons because that's
what what the game is barely about to to
catch them all - to complete your
pokedex than to train your Pokemon make
them better and gain prestige by by
owning these gems so the tagline got a
capture move it's not about getting
every single one it's about getting the
different types is it yes yeah yeah as I
said they're like 750 different ones I
believe and if you if you find the same
one again you do get some some bonus
experience points and some some Stardust
and candy and all these kind of things
but then you can exchange them form for
more bonus items etc so you you want to
have like one really strong Pokemon of
every type yeah that's that's an
interesting question many people ask
that already when Niantic was doing
ingress which is the the predecessor and
Pokemon you have the freemium model so
instead of instead of walking to the
poker stops and collecting new pokeballs
I can also be lazy and just pay pay
money and then then get these items so
that's one one business model
and the other interesting thing is by
following the people around the city and
observing how they move where they go
where they congregate etc Niantic also
learns a lot about the structure of the
city about people's movement etc and so
that's potentially very interesting data
to analyze and then use in other ways
than just gaming maybe some kind of
dates or harvesting well they they need
to do some data harvesting anyways
because that's what they are what the
game is all about to send people into
into unexplored environments for example
that that's also one of the the
fascinations that that the Pokemon Go
game has that you see that there's a
polka stop somewhere and that's why you
go then you go to an area of the city
that you haven't been before and so you
so you explore the city you learn you
you see the city with new eyes in a way
so you're doing sightseeing and you're
in your hometown which is something you
often don't actually do you think that
the people who are playing this game are
actually seeing any of the sights are
they just staring well that's that's
something I have noticed when I when I'm
playing the game and for example here at
the Market Square there's often a big
congregation of people playing the game
and yes people people look at their
phones and they look at the map so they
they can see where the poker stops are
etcetera and they've they've focused
very much on the map they catch the
pokemons with the augmented reality view
they do the flicking game etc and
sometimes they seem to be a bit remote
from the from the actual environment and
that's something that we and research
have tried to to investigate like what
makes these games exciting how much
coupling between the real world and the
virtual game space do you want to have
how does it change the game experience
because what neon tech is doing is they
have a big database of all these
landmarks where they place the poker
stops and the gems etc and so all of
these locations are at interesting
places but then again there's no strong
connection between the game content and
the actual location because if I go to
this poker stop or to this poker stop
that doesn't have any different meaning
another interesting question is is in a
way a legal question or an ethical
question because you're placing all
these virtual up
checks into the real world into the into
the cyberspace so to say so who owns the
cyberspace of your location if I if I
have if I live in my flat and then
because of how the game is set up a
Pikachu appears in my back garden that
will potentially attract other players
and they might then feel enticed to
climb it to my back garden and I don't
necessarily will feel that it's
something illegal they are doing because
the game kind of tells them there's a
Pikachu come here
pick up the Pikachu and then it becomes
an interesting question what happens if
there's an accident for example while
they're trespassing other cases that
have been in the media locations that
don't really want Pokemon to appear
there for example the Holocaust Museum
in New York or outfits cemeteries in
general so suddenly you have people
running around the cemetery holding up
their phones onto to graveyards so it's
an interesting social and ethical
question that you have to ask yourself
when you're designing these games and
when you add content to these games what
does that happen on those particular
places what what's causing those to
become hotspots
yeah because neon tech is using a very
simple trick so to say to create all the
content so they haven't gone and opened
Google Maps and place that polka stop
here another focus top here and here
should be a polka stop so they have a
they have a big database of locations
which they have increased by by the
previous game ingress and so now they
have a giant database of landmarks of
monuments of schools universities
statues etc and all of these locations
are chosen for the game and then
auto-generated as poker stops and gems
so there's no moderation process and
there at the moment you must immediately
get down base if they made it
Sheffield's it's a kind of drunk jelly
babies playing in a car park physics
roller game a chemical phone low this
particular server has four
Titan X graphics cards in it a Titan X
is one of the foremost graphics cards
there are new generation 10